Yeah.
Thank you for inviting me to talk to Google and a stay and as mentioned by
probiotic that I have been working for almost a decade now in this domain of
spreading cyber safety of Ns against cyber crimes.
I have spoken to say 2 million students in the country now and since 2008 I've
been doing it and my experiences that I personally receive 30 to 40 complaints
from these young kids every day when it comes to the online threats to children
and the age group,
like it starts with eight years and it goes up to 2122 school and college
students.
So I talked to school and college both.
The second role which I do is I trained law enforcement,
which I've been doing very actively since 2009 and right from top of the country
moved to south.
I've been traveling to various academies and empowering the law enforcement
officers.
First thing was the challenge to make them understand that cyber crime is not a
monster.
So Eh.
And the second was,
if you look at our NCRB status takes in India,
yes it is increasing.
The complaints are increasing many terms to frauds and uh,
uh,
any abuse on social media specifically to children?
I think there's something missing.
What is missing,
which I started promoting,
it's called netiquettes cyber hygiene,
digital wellness.
And I think it should become a part of the curriculum today.
Now why?
Because cyberbullying is on a rise.
That is another major challenge for every school and college.
Even any social media,
you pick up a messenger or you pick up a social media platform,
posting obscene content,
making more off pictures,
spreading rumors,
writing bad words.
It's a very common thing.
And the major thing which I see across is that they don't even know what are the
cyber laws.
So very famous line,
which I always say when I talk to children and it's always carrying with me,
that is virtual world is not a game.
It's your life.
So I,
I talk to children about cyber laws
for them,
creating a fake account is fun for them.
Hacking into an account to fund a sixth grader.
He stands up and says,
I'm a hacker.
And I asked him,
what do you do?
Ballet I have Wifi is when a why my mother doesn't give me Wifi.
So I had called my neighbors by five and how do you do it?
But I just got an application which is available.
I saw video,
I learned it and now I can hack by five.
So now this is a challenge making them understand that hacking is a crime.
Full Stop.
There is a simple section in one of the cyber laws information technology act,
which I call section 60 c which says that if fraudulently or dishonestly used in
somebody's password,
unique identity or electronic signature,
you are punishable for three years with the final one,
lack rupee.
And then I talk to children are very popular.
They say that only three years,
food and lodging is free.
So the message is very clear.
Hey listen,
hacking is a crime.
Same comes when we talk about the incidences of cyberbullying.
So just I came in the morning flight and I got a message from a young girl.
Somebody created a fake account and sharing and posting my personal content.
Now,
and this is a cyber crime in my country.
So there's a posting obscene content,
private content online I and the first line,
which is very popular line with every victim who's calling me,
don't tell it to my parents will kill me.
So this gap,
the digital divide.
When I talk to parents,
I do a lot of parents sessions.
Now why?
Because only because of this reason.
There's a big digital divide.
The parent will come and say,
I don't know what my tranquil do on iPhone.
He's such a brilliant boy or something like that.
But when it comes to you pay the children's,
say that we are teaching parents how to use technology,
it's good.
But are we teaching children netiquettes and cyber hygiene?
This is my point and that's how I cover up when I talk to them.
Law Enforcement.
The biggest challenge here in law enforcement today is that cybercrime is a
monster.
And when I talked to them,
I say it's not a monster,
the same crime.
But previously they used to come and rob my house or my bank locker.
Today they are doing it online.
Same.
I used to tease a girl.
There was FTZ today.
They do it online by creating some impersonating account or by posting some bad
pictures of words.
The only thing which they need to understand today here is that how do you
correlate all these service providers and how do you interact with them to
protect the law,
to punish them as per the information technology act,
which says that spreading any obscene content is a crime.
So they have a wonderful section here and it at call section 67 which says that
if you publish transplant or even become a reason to publish any obscene content
electronically,
you're punished for three years with a fine of five lakh rupees people at times
and fun.
They create messages on messengers,
different messengers,
chat messengers,
and the starts sending obscene content.
You are breaking the law.
Similarly comes with sexually explicit content section 67 67 eight it says that
any sexually explicit content,
if you're sharing electronically,
you're punishable for five years with a fine of 10 lakhs.
Non Billable people don't know these law
and a very common problem we should come across with young kids.
So I was in a relationship.
Okay.
I had a breakup.
Okay,
now this person is blackmailing me with my personal pictures.
16 is becoming a serious problem.
It's a psychological problem.
You young children,
they tend to share personal images and they think they think I'm sharing it on a
messenger.
It will be destroyed in three seconds.
I'm sorry.
Nothing gets destroyed.
So how to handle digital footprints is another.
The people who don't understand what a digital footprints and how they can
follow you for a lifetime.
So this is another thing which I interact when I talk to young minds and even
professional role.
So second days,
the challenge of handling such crimes.
Today something happened online and you know what kind of cases are coming when
it comes to bank froze everyday there will new modus operandi coming in to old
one.
I'm getting a call.
I got a call from a person who is calling from the bank.
He says that your bank account will be close because your ad hide is not linked
to your bank account and your account will become zero.
Oh don't close my account.
Then verify your account.
Give me your card details.
I gave my card details,
we are sending a message to verify whether it is you are not.
Please give us that message number.
Also,
he shared his OTP also and now he comes and file a complaint.
90,000 gone.
10 Rupee Balance and a,
we call it a cyber crime.
Second,
the most,
uh,
popular,
which is happening these days is skimming.
So now these hackers,
they have got access to those devices.
They can break a ATM or they can,
uh,
plan to small skimmer to the vendor windows machine where your car get duplicate
it.
Now,
if you look at the internationally,
everywhere,
you don't require a pin or an Otp to swipe a card.
It's only in India that you require a pin in and OTP.
So now the complaining comes to me and say,
is that my cyber cell that I was sleeping in the night and I had a $40,000
transaction on my car from some country in France or us.
The challenge for the law enforcement is that first of all,
they cannot go to us and France and investigate.
The second the money has been swiped.
It's a very popular technique and hackers are doing it in our country.
They call it garden.
So the Stele card information here and sell it for some peanuts to
international,
you can call organized criminals who have those groups somewhere where they just
pay them peanuts and there they use your card.
Same as happening,
reverse.
So there are foreigners whose cards have been cloned and skimmed in India.
This is cybercrime third most popular,
which I am seeing across now when I visit so many police stations and cyber
sellers,
man in the middle attack.
So the compromise,
our emails,
they get into our email settings.
We people hardly look at our settings on a daily basis.
They create filters and forwarders and they create tweet domains.
So my email id for example,
is infrastructure tendon dotcom.
The hacker creates infotrack Shit,
dawn,
dawn.com he just tweaks it from me too and he reads all my meals,
copy,
paste the trail,
take my invoice and send it to my buyer vendor saying that my bank account is
frozen duty,
GST audit.
So please kindly transfer my payment to my back bank London account.
And how much when like 25,000 euros gone,
this tour exporter,
he lost recently one and a half like euros just because of tweaking man in the
middle attack.
These are the organized crimes which we are seeing and they all started with the
email which used to come here,
a lucky winner,
Coca Cola,
$900 million and now it is transformed to this top talking of scams and I'm,
I got a call,
three girls the last two days have called me.
We got to link that somebody is posting some bad pictures on some social media.
I clicked on that link and my account got hacked.
Then all my friends in the network received a message that I'm in trouble.
Please deposit 701,000 or two piece to my so and so wallet.
I will return it to you as soon as possible.
All the respected friends were busy in their daily life and work.
So it is a matter of click on a smart phone to just go to your wallet and
transfer that amount.
And later they realized that her account was compromised and the hacker has
taken complete control.
Fishing,
peep,
Eh,
when I talk to people,
they're not able to understand what is fishing today.
They click on every mail.
One of,
recently I got a case from very big celebrity who's Icloud was hacked.
There's a smartphone cloud and how very simple.
He got a male and was a tweaking in spelling and he,
this lady entered her credentials cloud was hacked and all the personal pictures
were downloaded from a personal cloud and then starts talking in black Millie.
So these are the most popular,
when I say incidences and coming to the solutions,
what we do,
I try to tell them how to use an APP first.
So that is a basic thing.
People are not aware.
So if I'm using an APP,
they have wonderful features inside it,
which can help you to recover your account,
protect your account,
whether it's two step authentication.
The basic knowledge is missing.
And when you go down in the rural area,
everybody has a smart phone.
That day I,
I met a small vendor,
he asked me,
I had no cash.
So he said,
you can give it to me on my wallet.
So many who told you to use a wall?
It,
how do you know where the mobile recharge person?
He put Wallet Inside My,
in Brooklyn Hindy he said he has inserted this volatile assignment.
What is your wallet ID and Password Bully?
What is this?
He doesn't even knows that a wallet on a smartphone has an identity and a
password,
which he doesn't know.
So the challenge today we have is a handling this digital revolution.
So I always,
whenever I talk,
I always not only talk about digital India,
but I always talk about safer digital India.
And that is the word I tried to key is whether it's talking to children or
talking to adults and professionals with children.
Yes.
Uh,
we're doing a lot of work on online prediction and why?
Because 16 stalking and then these,
uh,
societal games coming up and suddenly trying to envelop the kids.
And you know what,
kids have curiosity.
They don't want to commit suicide.
I was talking to kids,
I recently,
last couple of weeks,
I've spoken to 25,000 kids in the country.
I was in good drought.
I was in Djenne,
I was in north Delhi and all schools,
they wanted to see what is it exactly,
how does one person commits suicide?
And you know,
the modus operandi,
they,
they just tried to blackmail you and stalk you.
And then they tried to,
and whosoever these societal curators and Admin so called lab.
So there is a need of awareness in our children.
And uh,
they are curious about everything.
Whether,
and I have seen children,
they don't even know how can they secure their applications,
whether,
whether it's a popular video channel or it's a popular search engine.
They don't even know that there are some settings which can prevent them from
harm.
And not only them.
When I talked to the ICT,
there's a big gap I see is very good in teaching the school a ICT syllabus,
right?
The program and put a number and generate the femoral series.
They're excellent in doing that,
but when it comes to hacking and stuff,
you will find the eighth grader talking and dive.
I know how to use Kali Unix.
I can create a Metasploit and all those words you start speaking and that really
scares and then even ask me,
I have confronted these questions from young minds.
What if I'm using a tor browser,
how we'll do crack me and when or which class you are in Bulla seventh standard.
When you come to me separately,
I will tell you how to trace a tor browser.
So these,
you know what the explosion is there when it comes to information or,
but the mindset is not ready for it.
So to prepare that mindset is also very important.
Whether it's your gaming habits or it's your social media habits.
Law of crimes have been reported because people,
they don't even know what are the privacy features.
I remember when case in it was five years back to now we have that security by
by the government of India that even if I change the Sim card,
my SMS service will not work for a limited time.
You know what used to happen,
identity theft,
how the hacker will get access to your date of birth from social media side,
get access to your personal information like people love to post today on any
popular social media.
There are so many international days we are celebrating today.
Happy Mother's Day.
I love my mom come lot baby.
So my mom name is available on the site and that is a secret question and answer
to one of my online banking detail.
The hacker very conveniently Vanc and he issued a Sim card of that with him.
The moment he got access to the same car,
he got access to the mobile banking network and he immediately swiped all the
money out.
This all money was taken out with the help of and this gentleman,
he was sitting in his office and he taught my network is not coming.
The message on the phone was sim unregistered.
He tried to plug out the same,
put it back,
nothing happened after some hours he went to the mobile.
You can't be in the set.
Listen,
your same goddess corrupted.
Take a new one,
you've got a new Sim card.
And after five hours of activation,
he realized that all the bank is empty.
When we started getting such cases of identity tab debtors when an action was
taken.
And now today we are preventing Your Sim misuse by locking your SMSs for a
period of time.
But hackers are very smart.
You create one rule,
they know how to break the other one.
So looking at the old case studies,
it is very important to promote education awareness.
Uh,
there is a very popular app where you can synchronize the APP on your computer.
So that's the messenger app where you just particularly scan a QR code.
When I talk to people,
yeah,
70% are not aware of that option.
And I am receiving complaints where a person come and see.
So I have this personal messenger APP on my mobile.
You can,
anybody else wants to use it?
And I go,
yes.
Well if somebody's phone is hacked because I have north center mass message to
anybody,
but some,
all our complaining that you are sending some bag bag messages and I have not
sent it and it is going from my messenger.
When I checked his phone,
his phone was already sinked into another device.
And that device was somebody else who was using that application.
So this is a challenge,
uh,
when it comes to and at the ground level.
Yes,
people are not aware.
You have to play a very proactive role today.
And the best way is toxic start impacting this education to the young minds and,
uh,
at the root level because they also need this training on bullying and stalking.
And,
uh,
well,
I,
I keep up children,
especially,
I got a case where a person created a fake email account impersonating account
and send a very different married to another child.
You know,
what happened?
That child was into depression for two,
three days.
And you know,
what is the age of that child live in years,
11 years
for 10 kids.
It's a prank.
And I'm sorry for me as for the Itx Itsa offense because it exists,
but nation is a crime section 66 d clicking personal pictures and sharing is a
crime.
So we have special uh,
act,
uh,
section in the it act with say section 66 he captured in publishing and
transmitting image of a private area of any person without his or her consent.
Three years of punishment,
two lakh rupees,
fine or both.
And sexting.
Oh my God.
Approximately five years back,
I used to get one or two complaints in a month.
I'm sorry.
Today I'm 15 to 20.
The more and more kids go in the country,
the more and more,
uh,
such problems.
I keep on hearing personal pictures going viral.
Social exclusion is there in children.
They have complexes.
You know,
what are the complexes?
Body shame.
But shame is becoming alon blacks.
This young girl I did not got likes on my picture on the social media.
So I'm having depression.
Yes,
they have depression now.
So to talk to them in this.
And,
and I have realized that there is a big gap now children and especially the
young ones there.
So getting addicted to,
I'm using the word addiction now,
Eh,
I teach the positive use.
I,
one of my,
uh,
my own family,
there was an issue where this,
he was having a dead addiction to playing these Voiland games and there was a
lot of transformation in his behavior.
So he was getting violent at home,
aggressive.
He used to throw things and break things.
And I asked a simple question,
which game does he play?
Ball,
he plays this wall in game.
How much?
Three to four hours a day,
three to four hours a day.
And you will understand today that in child psychology,
whatever you see you in you,
it's like a simple osmosis going on.
So if I'm playing while in games for the whole day,
I'm imbibing while an aggression in my nature.
So I shifted him and I said,
okay,
you create this wonderful channel on a social media site and you start playing
your keyboard and your guitar and then see you will start monetizing it and you
can earn money.
And it really worked as a magic and he's now out of his addiction.
And today he's more concerned about his channel and he's creating new content,
sharing,
liking us comments.
And everyday he's respecting all the comments and then he's responding to them.
And I could,
I could easily grab,
brought him out from the negative part of the addiction to a positive side of
the neck.
So this is another thing.
And I started one wonderful activity after addressing more than 25,000 schools
in the country,
uh,
and colleges,
I started creating salts,
my sites,
many cyber cells in the school.
I,
you give the name Cyber Congress.
So I do this kind of an effort where I trained them for eight hours to 10 hours,
a handful of students who are the good and empathy and all.
I called them the cyber captains of the school,
their counselors and their ICT stuff in a closed room and they do two things
now.
They help children with problems.
They know the wrestle park,
they know right from how to talk to the service provider and how to come back
out of her problem.
What is the rehearsal?
Number two,
they inculcate positive Internet habits in the country,
so that is another,
I've seen a wonderful change when if you,
because he children don't know what to do on Internet because the Internet was
never a subject in a country for them.
Social media is Internet,
so they never got trained.
Yes,
they've got trained in C and C plus plus and website development and PHP and
html.
That was a part of the syllabus but not a single class has ever taught you.
Even I talk to children,
they don't even know the full form of gprs.
Very Fun,
fun and funny.
And then I have to tell the managers,
good rod partner at TCM law,
so we'll no,
no,
no.
Monica note is global something many?
No,
no,
no.
It is general packet radio service.
The same thing,
which you are using 24 hours on your smartphone.
So to create that positive impact,
I started inculcating this cyber congress thing and that has been very
successful and you know what I do also,
I give surveys to them every three months,
a small survey,
internal survey with all the kids to tell about their online habits and their
issues.
And after the Cyber Congress implementation,
the problems which are reported on the first day of say 60% children having
problems of bullying,
stalking or defamation or something is coming down to 25 and 15% after every
three months,
the issue is falling.
So if I know how to be responsible online from the day one,
because then I think when you go become a senior also,
you know what?
Our digital footprints,
no you will.
Nobody will mess up.
And the basic things like don't share your passwords.
They don't share your credit card numbers with anybody.
Don't give your card to the vendor.
People give their car.
I asked them,
do you give you a wallet to the person?
Okay,
take my wallet and get me some 10 rupees stuff from the market.
Take my wallet and go,
no,
you don't give your wallet it then how can you give your evil it to anybody?
This debit card or credit card is called the Ebola.
Now you give you a wallet and then you come and complain that my card is in my
pocket and somebody has to draw money from Delhi ATM.
Your car got cloned.
So there are these uh,
organized criminals who are misusing all these techniques,
which people so to how to prevent this.
So number one,
you're not giving your car to anybody.
I also teach people to know,
remove the CVV number from the backside of your card.
Take a black marker and erase it and keep it safe.
Because if I come to know your card number and CVV,
I don't need any other authentication online to go to any market place and do
shopping.
And that is what is happening.
So preventing that.
So these simple do's and don'ts have,
we are trying to create to spread the Savannah's and the challenges.
Yes,
there are challenges because if you look at the policing in India,
so we pull the thing,
it was the actual work.
The maximum force of the police is the,
uh,
the constables,
the head constables and the southern specters.
Then the,
its officers and those relations are igs and SSPS.
Actual work is to be done by the maximum.
This force,
which is your constables and all.
So their basic training.
You know what I,
when they,
they think cybercrime training means somebody something specialized.
You have to be a biotech or a or a master in computer science.
Sorry,
I,
whenever I go to and with,
when you want to investigate cyber crime,
you only need to do things.
We'll work two things many years,
right?
Then you will receive an email,
sing,
receive an email.
If you notice,
you can investigate any crime,
whether it's a social media abuse,
a bank,
fraud in ATM fraud,
because all the information today for these crimes are with the service provider
and you need to know the legal and the standard process to ask this information.
Once you get this information,
then you have to do traditional policing.
So I came to know that this is the mobile handset of Russia.
Tanglin Internet connection or Rakshit.
Tandon has committed this offense,
so now I have to do traditional policy and go in arrest fracture tendon.
Next step is the proper Caesar so that the digital evidence is collected
properly and then the law,
the role of the forensic labs,
which is again a challenge right now because the load is high,
the complaints are higher.
I was just looking at the figures of cert and it was in the newspapers recently
with said from January,
2017 to June,
2017 we have reported somewhere around 27,482 cases.
So that is making out to be approximately every 10 minute one cases happening.
That does means that the reporting is there.
I will take it positively because if I look at the police reports 10 years back
when I started working,
they were not taking complaints.
So when there were no complaints,
then the records were also not showing.
But today that taking complaints and the RST is also there and you know what is
a sad part of the arrest.
And look at the fifth 2015 analisis of hence CRB a 5,108 people were escalate,
committing cybercrime 3,188 we're in the age group of 18 to 30 and 98 we're in
the age group of 18 below
18 below.
Now this two things,
if you look at that means what young people recently I saw on the newspaper also
in one of our agencies confirmed it to me,
you know,
to Predation Deli Palace.
They busted a racket where four young guys were arrested who had been to an
online portal and using the technique of data tempering or something and they
stole 94 lakh rupees vouchers or something and they were all young minds there
it students and they call themselves ethical hackers.
Now this is a challenge here.
The thin line between ethical hacking and there's crime.
So I at the end,
it again comes back to the same thing,
teach them laws.
They don't even know what are the laws and a number two,
uh,
organizations now need to be proactive.
Don't wait for something to happen.
So I,
I today the mindset is that I will go and buy the best laptop from the showroom,
but when it comes to software,
worry free download today,
pirated.
And then I complained of cyber attacks.
So it's very sad when I come to know that most of our important facilities are
still running on old obsolete to us.
And when I,
when I take talk shows in the people as it,
so I've heard that of anybody can hack your phone in five second Monica.
Yes.
When,
which phone are you using?
okay,
what is the version of your oms?
So it's five or 4.0.
When a please go and put it on the high way,
way below the track.
It will be better.
It will have,
it will rest in peace.
So the people are not understanding because if you're OSTP or your operating
system is vulnerable to attacks,
it can easily be hacked.
So people,
first thing has to be educated.
Here is also how to be proactive in security.
Do stone wait for something programmers,
they don't know the secure coding framework.
So now when I talk to engineering students,
I tell them see it very easy to become an ethical hacker to find a loophole and
exploited,
but it's more difficult to create a code which nobody can hack and that is where
the exact potential lies.
So right now we are learning programming and you are in the first year of
education and you want to develop a mobile app,
you want to develop a website,
start working on this and how to do this when you have to learn three aspects,
attack,
defense and response.
Until unless you don't know attack,
you cannot create a defense and response.
So yes,
he will have to think like a hacker.
You will have to know all the vulnerabilities and all the bad part of the coding
and operating systems and databases.
And there you will have to play a positive role in touching that up and creating
an application outside in the market.
90% of the applications,
they are launched in the market and they're not tested.
And when they are not tested,
then you hear a very bad news in the newspaper,
x,
y,
zed APP,
1.41 point 5 billion data breached and out.
All the customer data is in public in the black market and who's the victim?
The consumer is a victim.
So this is how the old everything is flowing today and a new new modus operandi
is,
are coming out and hackers are very proactive.
I that day was handling a case where this a very simple complaint of a normal
kidnapping case,
kidnapping case to place and the ransom was claimed on,
uh,
we owe IP call.
So some birth downloaded a third party application that you,
millions of third party applications available online where you can create a
call and the calling number would be very funny.
Something like a three digit number or a four digit number or a 13 digit number.
Today,
the law enforcement in my country is very smart and handling mobile
surveillance.
We have been trained,
it's been 10 years now.
We play with mobile surveillance,
but then people have left using mobiles.
Now you don't use mobiles.
Now if you've taken the second step,
that is called Internet calling.
So now that again becomes a challenge for law enforcement and been this kind of
cases are reported the police,
this is a matter of cybercrime sell.
Why?
Because the call is coming through Internet.
So these are the latest challenges we are facing.
And one more challenge,
which I think is a big threat right now is these virtual numbers which are
existing online and a wet.
And especially in a country where we are trying to bring so many wallets,
we are trying to bring so many mobile wallets and all these numbers are
authenticated using her mobile number or a number,
we call it a number.
So you can start using a wallet until,
unless you have a number.
And for that number,
we simply use that authentication,
which is the SMS authentication.
So what's your number is becoming a threat.
And uh,
but then that is what will thing is a,
it's like a mouse Katonah mouse race.
And uh,
and this is how cybercrimes is evolving in India.
Thank you.